Resident Evil is a third-person survival
horror classic which lost its way a bit
and became an action shooter for some
reason with the imminent arrival of
Resident Evil 7 the game has gone back
to a slope is survival horror routes
utilizing a first-person perspective
Capcom have been teasing this game for
months now and have released ten videos
around 30 seconds in length from these
tiny teasers here are 10 things that we
know about Resident Evil 7 the mystery
caller if you've already played the demo
you probably found the first telephone
which rang incessantly it appears the
caller who many believe is Ada Wong from
previous resi games will offer
information and guide the player through
the events of re 7 the second teaser
named shotgun in a box demonstrates a
few of the weapons in the game the
character pulls out a shotgun but we
also see handgun ammo and the knife in
his possession and if you remember the
demo we also had a hatchet to wield to
teaser three named recorder demonstrates
the save mechanic in Resident Evil 7
gone are the typewriters replaced with
cassette tips which will probably feel
just as archaic if you're born this side
of the millennium
stock up is the 4th video we see the
destructible items in the game a knife
is used to smash a crate off but more
importantly the steam knife is used to
Jimmy open an electrical box
hopefully that represents a more
realistic Resident Evil 7 where
equipment has multiple functions vol 5
is simply entitled survival and depicts
our character locating herbes like in
the original Resident Evil he combines
the herb with cherry fluid to create a
medicine which he then pours all over
himself this tells us our mortality is
important so stock up on all those herbs
the next teaser is the pick of the bunch
and includes action after taking a
mixing axe to the chest you rise up and
shoot the off ball in the heart he dies
and you stumble ah but wait he's not
dead this could be the return of the
indestructible characters like the
Nemesis or it could even mean you'll
have to find a certain weakness in your
vault either way this is bloody
frightening volume 7 demonstrates
another game mechanic which allows you
to rotate an object and look for a clue
this was around in the early Resident
Evil games where books must be open to
find the correct page or object the next
video is titled imagination and has me a
little confused our character place is a
straw doll on a pedestal which then
becomes other items ranging from a knife
to a balloon what on earth could this
mean the penultimate video is named
shadow and depicts a tiny element of a
fight with something that resembles the
regenerators from Resident Evil 4 this
suggests we may need to run away from
some of the stronger enemies the final
video is here to scare the bejesus out
of us and shows our hero attempting to
locate a woman's homes
the shot ends before we can see the full
story but she either looks dead on
moments away from it so that's 10 things
we've learned from the Resident Evil
teasers have we missed anything and will
you be getting this game let us know
below the release date is January 24th
and I personally cannot wait please give
us a like and subscribe as we really
need your support I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade I'll see you next
time